this is from USA Today it says uh they
say students have fallen three grade
levels behind they say Behavior has
never been worse they say it's as if
they have to teach people who have only
Built one-story houses how to build
skyscrapers and they say they've been
too scared to talk about it until now
teachers are taking to Tik Tok to
express their fears frustrations and
worries about the state of education
more than three years after the co 19
pandemic prompted school shutdowns and
remote learning Nationwide though the
problem of some students underperforming
is nothing new many teachers say the gap
between where kids are and where they
ought to be has never been more
staggering to make matters worse these
teachers say the education system isn't
doing enough to address the issue and
that most of their colleagues are too
scared to call it out publicly but
thanks to a new viral video they say
they feel embolden validated and feel
free to say their peace it all started
when a seventh grade teacher in Georgia
spoke out on Tik Tok last week about how
much kids are struggling revealing most
of his students entered the school year
performing at a fourth grade level or
lower so this is the uh original viral
video maybe you've seen this and it's
got something like four million views at
this point with a teacher talking about
what it's like in his classroom and how
far behind the kids are in his seventh
grade classroom and then many other
teachers have joined in and said yeah
this is exactly what I'm experiencing as
well so before we talk about it let's
watch uh the video from this
teacher no y'all can we talk about it
can we please talk about it let's take a
moment to discuss let's take a moment to
debrief let's take a moment to unpack so
I'm not really understanding why they
not telling y'all like we all know that
the world is behind like you know
globally like you know because of the
pandemic and stuff but I don't
understand why they not stress to y'all
how bad it is like I'm not even trying
to be funny but these kids
are I'm going just say this I teach
seventh grade they are still performing
on the fourth grade
level I don't care how you flip it turn
it swing swing it swle it they still
performing on a fourth grade level a't
nobody talking about how they just keep
moving passing them on they just keep
passing them on passing them on passing
them on passing them on passing them on
pass them I can put as many zos in this
gra as I want to they going to move that
child to the eth grade next year ain't
nobody talking about that why they not
talking about that why they not telling
y'all that Y and why don't y'all know
that y'all kids not performing on that
great level why y'all don't know this
why y'all don't know talk about it let's
unpack because y'all be quick to talk
about oh the teacher this the teacher
this the it's your job it's your job
baby I just got here 30 days ago she was
performing on the fourth grade level
since fourth
grade why we not talk let's talk about
it you're the teacher you supposed to be
again sheep been on the fourth grade
level since the fourth grade we in
seventh grade now so you let this child
go 3 years and you never knew that your
child was still in the fourth grade
ain't never left
the hang it up flat screen in fourth
grade is being nice I still have kids
performing on grade K 1 2 and third
grade levels I could probably count on
one hand how many kids are actually
performing on a grade level so just
imagine you don't know that CH been on
the second grade level since the second
grade and they now in the seventh or
eighth
grade are you joking right now and these
our Future Leaders our future doctors
our future nurses F please
please uh let's talk about he said well
he says let's unpack twice uh you don't
need to use that phrase once in once in
your life really certainly not twice in
a in a 90 second video but putting that
aside
um okay uh yeah it is it is something we
should talk about and it is it is like a
it's it's a Maj it's just it's a major
problem I I don't know how else to to
put it we've got gener generation of
kids who are who are not being educated
and who they're going to graduate like
barely knowing how to read okay it's
coming it's it's it's happening right
now um everything idiocracy you know
that that movie imagined I think it was
500 years in the future when we lived in
a in a in a in a world dominated by sub
75 IQ morons uh that was being way too
optimistic 500 years okay we're talking
about the next like 5 years that's what
we're looking at if we're not already
there um and yes it is a major problem
and he's right to point it out he's also
right that um he's right to put much of
the responsibility on parents because
there are a lot of parents who are
not aware of their own child's abilities
and their own child's struggles they're
not aware of it or don't seem to be
concerned about it um they're not
working with their kids this is not the
case for every parent at all and I I
don't even know if we could say most
parents but there's certainly a large
preponderance of parents way too many I
mean one is too many but there's way too
many parents who are um not concerned
with their kids education they just ship
the kid off to school and then they the
kid comes home and they just assume it's
like well they've taken care of that and
the kid comes home and and they're just
they're playing video games or they're
on TV they're on their phones and that's
all they do and that's all that's all
the parents want to do also which is
part of the problem all the parents want
to do is be on their phone staring at
screens and so that's all the kids do
when they're at home and there's no kind
of real intellectual life intellectual
engagement of any kind between parent
and child and um and then and then for a
lot of these teachers they're they
become very frustrated because then they
try to talk to the parents about it
parents don't want to hear it and then
they just put they put the onus back on
the school and so that's what goes on um
and so that is that's true and that's a
major problem however it is also true
that the school system itself and the
teachers themselves bear an amount of
responsibility here as well and uh when
I watch a video like that and I see a
lot of these other teachers that are
joining in I don't see enough personal
responsibility yeah you're calling on
parents to take responsibility great
fine agreed but where is your personal
responsibility okay it's it's easy
enough to say oh I just got here 30 days
ago fine that might be the case for you
personally with with this next group of
children when the school in the school
system the school year just started last
month but um teach the the school system
itself and the school system is run when
we're talking about the school system
we're talking about teachers and
administrators okay the system is not
some sort of uh organism it's it's
comprised of in of people and so we're
talking about teachers and
administrators and they have also failed
miserably and I don't hear I don't hear
nearly enough discussion about that I
mean you want to have a conversation
this guy is saying let's let's talk
about let's have a okay let's let's have
it so what's going on on your end why
have you guys failed so catastrophically
because the thing is this problem is not
it didn't just start now in fact it's
been trending this way for decades okay
it's been trending this way for a long
time years and years and years way
before Co it was trending in this
direction we already had a major problem
years ago of people graduating high
school with no grasp on basic subjects
like Civics geography history we already
had a major problem of of kids coming
out of high school 18 years years old
and if you ask
them you know to name 10 of the 50
states in the country they'd be stumped
okay if you ask them to to to tell you
uh what century the civil war occurred
in they'd be stumped so we already had
that problem and now the problem is
getting much worse and there's no way to
you can't absolve the parents but you
also can't absolve the education system
itself which very which too often uh is
how this conversation goes it's actually
it's easy to blame the parents everybody
blames the parents everyone blames the
parents for everything and any problem
that that happens in society we all turn
to the parents say oh it's all bad
parenting and that's there's always an
element of that okay there's truth to
that but that's the easy thing to
say um what's more difficult what people
don't want to say is you know what we
also have a problem of there are a lot
of really bad teachers they're just bad
at their
jobs on top of the bad parents we also
have bad teachers I've got to tell you
about something that speaks to the very
core of our values as Americans about a
veteran-owned company on a mission to
make a real difference in the lives of
our military members I'm talking about
pure talk here's the deal why we
absolutely love what they're doing our
veterans gave everything to protect our
nation and Pure Talk understands the
sacrifices they've made they've set an
ambitious goal to eliminate $10 million
in military debt by Veterans Day but
they can't do it alone they need your
help when you switch to Pure Talk's
Lightning Fast 5G Network they'll donate
a portion of every new to this noble
cause you can make a real difference
just by choosing Superior cell phone
service it's that simple peer talks
plans started just 20 bucks a month
offering unlimited talk text more data
and a mobile hotspot just go to Pur
talk.com Walsh and make the switch let's
rally together and show our unwavering
support for our veterans visit Pur
talk.com Walsh and switch to Pur talk
today it's the right move and it's the
American way and we have an education
system yeah it's true that if you're if
you know you send your kid off to the
education system you should
not just
assume that that takes care of it and
you don't have to participate in your
own kids's education you shouldn't
assume that so no matter where you send
your kid to to be educated or if they
are educated at home in homeschooling
environment either way you you should be
participating actively every day in your
child's
education that's true but also we do
have this thing in this country called
the education
system and so it's not unreasonable for
parents to expect that if they send
their kid to the education system that
their kid will be educated in that
system and that's not happening at all
for a lot of these
kids and and when we hear
representatives of the education system
talking about it they they always put
the onus back on the parents they never
take any responsibility for it
themselves they refuse to and if you try
to if you
everyone acknowledges that there are bad
parents out there but the moment you say
you no there are also Bad Teachers how
dare you teachers are Saints they're
they're Martyrs they're they're they're
perfect in every way Bad Teachers how
dare you no you know what there are a
lot of horrible stupid
teachers who who don't even have a grasp
of the subject that they're supposed to
be teaching that is also the
case and until you're willing to talk
about that you're not actually ready for
this conversation at all
guess what also uh we can't put all the
blame on Co here but the but that's that
is a that that really um Amplified the
problem and It sped up a lot of these
Trends okay that a lot of these
troubling trends that we already saw
well who decided to shut the schools
down and in fact who who was in the
streets marching demanding that the
schools stay
closed who was that who was was the
teachers wasn't
it the teachers were marching in the
streets demanding that they that schools
remain closed for their own sake because
they're so scared of getting a
cold any accountability for
that schools closing that was the
schools themselves were behind
that and insisted on it and for a lot of
these teachers you know schools opened
up again across the country I mean they
they closed for at Le almost every
school was closed for at least like half
a year which is a long time for a child
to miss out on education some of them
were closed for over a year a year and a
half but when they did start opening up
again it the teachers were the ones
saying keep them
closed I don't know if if the if Randy
weine garden and Company had their way
maybe the schools would still be closed
I don't know if it was really up to
them so maybe there should have been
more teachers I know I know it wasn't
every teacher there were some teachers
said from the beginning no schools need
to stay open you can't just stop
educating kids you can't do
that but there weren't nearly enough so
maybe there should have been more
teachers who who instead of being out in
the street say no keep them closed I'm
scared I don't want to get a
cold maybe there should have been more
teachers in the street saying open these
schools up we need to educate our
children we care about them you know
what maybe there should have been more
teachers saying you know what I I am
willing to risk getting sick for the
sake of of of of educating that that's
how much I care about my
job I'm willing to make that
sacrifice if you weren't willing to make
the sacrifice if you're so terrified of
getting a cold because you're a coward
that you're willing to sacrifice the
child's education then don't come
complaining now what about that guy I
mean I have no idea with that guy I have
no idea where he was on coid back in
2020 maybe he wasn't even teaching at
the time I don't
know
but and I could be totally wrong about
this I would be somewhat
surprised if it turned out that that guy
in particular back in 2020 was was was a
voice crying out in the wilderness and
keep the schools
open could be wrong but one thing I can
say a lot of a lot of teachers now are
complaining about kids are far behind
and I know for a fact that many of those
teachers were not only happy that
schools closed but were insistent on it
and wanted to keep them closed for
longer
and now they pretend to be so
concerned um you know now when it's like
too late honestly I hate to say it but
it's too late for a lot of these kids a
lot of these kids they don't have they
don't have parents who are going to
teach them they just don't they should
but they they
don't and you sacrificed the year of
educa of of whatever education they were
getting in the public school system you
sacrificed a year of it and they fell
way behind and and they haven't been
able to catch up and uh and now a lot of
those kids are feeling just like
overwhelmed and and they've given
up you know what happened the school
system gave up on these
kids around coid and a lot of the kids
have responded by giving up on school
that's what's going on here hey YouTube
thanks for listening to the show if
you'd like access to my full show with
no ads you should go to dailywire.com
and use promo code Walsh to get two
months free on all annual plan plans see
you there